no it's quite fantastic what's happening
right now you suddenly have the people
that have been pushing critical race
theory on everybody running away from
critical race theory
or admitting that they don't know what
it is or acting like
complete clowns like joy reid i mean
imagine john you
inviting someone on your show to treat
them that way
she may disagree with ruffo's assessment
of what critical race theory is or his
prescriptions on how we can move forward
or whether or not we should teach it etc
etc
but to just bring someone on to berate
them and belittle them and really just
act like a child
you know msnbc though is so bad it
almost makes cnn look like a news
network so that's that's kind of
impressive
in and of itself uh but look i think
that those of us that are fighting
critical race theory whether it's
people like you and i who are public
people or whether it's the average
parent
who's got a kid in school that doesn't
want their child to be taught about
raci race essentialism in essence that
race is the most important thing
and that you're born guilty if you're
white and you're somehow born better in
essence if you're brown or black
if you don't want those things taught in
some ways we can't over
intellectualize this argument if we're
constantly
go looking at their literature and
trying to punch holes in it and the rest
of it
well then we're just going to get caught
in some of the semantic games that chris
pointed out
to joy i think we have to just be clear
and concise with our language
do you want your children taught that
race is the most important thing
yes or no do you want them taught that
america is fundamentally evil and that
slavery
was the most important piece of our
founding yes or no we can do some basic
things like that
that's how you beat these guys because
you can get to what people really know
is true it's john you're not going to
believe this i don't care about people's
skin color
yeah and if you're and if you're a black
kid or a white kid or an
asian kid or whatever else i want you
treated equally and fairly and that's
the best that a civil society can do
i mean and that's the question you got
to ask and what what roofo's point is
here is you got to get specific with
people who advocate
for these policies call them out on it
name specific names i'm going to talk
about this with matt gates coming up in
the next segment as well
you know he had that dust up with the
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff
yesterday but you got to get specific
because this stuff is actually happening
and joy reid
wants to tell us that it's not happening
in schools we have evidence to the
contrary
uh you know the same thing they want us
to believe too dave is that you know
guys like you and i we never learned
about
you know slavery and that uh there were
actually slave owners i
i learned about the ku klux klan when i
was in grade school and middle school
and
you know i pointed out the other day
that i think i talked to you about this
when i was in eighth grade they showed
us pictures of emmett till in the
lynching and we learned about the hard
lessons but joy reid
you know she's one of these people that
will tell you that oh you know they
don't teach that stuff in school these
days
it's a blatant lie it's a blatant
lie and they know that they're lying and
they know that we know that they're
lying and they continue to
lie that is the game that they are
playing
everyone in america every i guarantee
you john
every single person watching this right
now was taught about slavery
uh in in school they were taught about
racial injustice they were
taught about martin luther king jr which
by the way i'm all for the
being taught yes those things you know
i'm not a big fan at this point of
public education and i don't think
anyone with their head on straight could
be at this point but i understand
that not everyone can afford charter
schools or private schools which is why
personally i would be for funding
children you know you fund the child not
the school but that's sort of a separate
issue
but the point is they're lying because
the new meme because they're starting to
lose
the narrative on critical race theory
the new meme is oh the republicans or
the conservatives don't want anyone to
learn about racism this is simply a lie
every single child in america is taught
about racism i have
never once heard anyone anyone
say that we should not teach about uh
mlk or we should not teach about slavery
or civil rights or anything like that
literally nobody right you know a lot of
republicans do like to teach
the fact that it was abraham lincoln a
republican uh
who actually you know signed the
emancipation proclamation you know and
but that's the thing is you know one
side is willing to talk about all
aspects of this the good the bad and the
ugly
uh the one side the other side and
that's joy reid and those who are
proponents of critical race there
whatever they want to call it nowadays
they only want to tell their side of the
story right now and that is what you
laid out there that america was founded
to industrialize slavery around the
world that it's inherently racist as a
nation
and that your future is predetermined by
the color of your skin
but let's leave that there because
there's plenty of other stuff to talk
about including f-15s dave
and nuclear weapons you know we used to
talk about the nuclear option being
something that relates to the filibuster
and judicial nominees but now we're
talking about it
for second amendment advocates uh joe
biden if you wanted to or if you think
that you need to have weapons to take on
the government you need f-15s and maybe
some nuclear weapons
you know the taliban are over in uh
afghanistan right now kind of laughing
at that statement well john first off
biden just made the greatest
argument for the second amendment and
for
your right as a citizen your god-given
right protected in the second amendment
to own and bear arms because he's
basically saying we the government we've
got a lot of weapons f-15s nukes
a whole bunch of stuff so unless you
think you can get those things you
better sit back and be quiet so he
actually made the most
pro-second amendment argument that there
is which by the way it doesn't surprise
me that biden's making a sort of
backwards circular logic argument
because i'm not sure he knows exactly
where he is
anyway but this is this is just one of
those things where
again everything that comes out of the
left is a lie
we have background checks now we can
talk about the gun show loophole which
they love and there's
certain things that perhaps we could tie
up but we know that the people who do
the mass shootings are not members
of the nra in almost every instance they
have not bought their guns
legally we have background checks
related to psychological problems and a
whole series of other things
so they just keep lying and keep lying
in
in the goal of just taking weapons away
from people and by the way the average
person in america we know that you know
there was a huge amount of
guns bought in the last year i'm a first
time gun owner i have several guns now
first time
in the last year it's because people are
watching cities defund the police and
they're watching crime ramping
everywhere
people are not buying guns so that they
they hopefully have to attack the
government it's not yeah you should have
a right to defend yourself from tyranny
i just watched a documentary on thomas
jefferson this morning on youtube and
that's
the whole point of the second amendment
but the point is people want to be able
to protect themselves that is your
god-given right
and and something that's enshrined to us
and we must protect
from people like joe biden the tree of
liberty is watered with the blood of
patriots that was the quote he kind of
botched again yesterday maybe
the president should avoid these quotes
you know i talk to people too and they
they talk to me about guns or you know
they ask me how many guns i have like
well you you seem to like guns and i was
like well i like guns as much as the
next
red-blooded american but what i really
like is the constitution when you
advocate
and that's again what the left doesn't
quite understand is for the right it's
about the constitution
and the second amendment doesn't have
anything to do with hunting or you know
magazines or clips or whatever you want
to call them
it's about the right to keep and bear
arms
and holding the government accountable
the tyrannical governments accountable
just like we did the british
all right speaking of tyrants let's move
on to gavin newsom now
uh i'm calling him uh governor nero
because he is fiddling why california
burns and dave i've been covering this
story i mean they're gonna spend a lot
of money like two billion dollars on
fire mitigation this was after
the media and the left you know mocked
president trump for saying this was a
big issue and then gavin newsom gets
caught by
california public radio of all people
lying about it vastly overstating how
much he has done for fire mitigation why
people's homes and businesses burn
gavin newsom is a liar and a fraud and a
con man and looks like he was
should have been cast in the movie
american psycho that that we look at
that picture i mean come on man that
that is
that was like joe biden impression did
you get that come on man uh but gavin
newsom look
he right now if you want whether you
like avenues or don't like avenues there
is some an interesting experiment
happening right now which is that
because of the recall because
1.7 million californians not crazy
right-wing maniacs as all of the
commercials are saying
you know that this was a right-wing ploy
that's what bernie said to you know
upend democracy by getting rid of gavin
1.7 million america uh californians who
were locked in their homes and lost
their jobs and had their businesses
closed
they said we want to get rid of this guy
who's racking up a 20k
alcohol bill at french laundry one of
the most expensive restaurants in
california
but what's interesting by doing the
recall there are some things happening
right now in california
uh john i think you're coming to my big
45th birthday party this weekend and
callie i don't know that you want that
known that you're going to be in crazy
los angeles but
i'm very happy to report that at the
underpass near my house where the
highways converge
there has been a massive homeless
encampment with dozens and dozens of
people basically building apartments for
months
and it's gone suddenly and that's not a
coincidence it's that
newsom realizes he has a little window
right now basically the summer
to clean up the city of l.a but broadly
the state
otherwise he actually will get recalled
and someone else will be voted in so the
point is that
public pressure when we use public
pressure and say no
you cannot be a tyrannical overlord
we're going to do something about it we
we the people are going to fight back
then you can make them do something so
regardless of whether newsom
i i don't want him to win the recall
obviously but whatever happens then at
least some good things are happening now
because
some good people chose to fight back and
they're not right wing maniacs
for doing so if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell